تبدأ المركبة الفضائية في تأرجحها لأعلى
ومواءمتها بشكل مثالي
مع منفذ الإرساء النهائي الخاص بها ، حيث
ستنضم سيارة soyuz هذه إلى الطرف الخلفي
من المحطة إلى
وحدة خدمة zvezda ، وبالتالي
سنرى بعض الحركة على النحو التالي  إنه يتأرجح
بعيدًا عن الأرض ويصطف في
النهاية مع
وضع الاستعداد لمنفذ الإرساء لذلك في حوالي دقيقة أو لذلك
هذا رائع ،
هذا هو النطاق الحالي ومعدل الإغلاق
1.2
نحن على استعداد للحصول على نسخة ممر نهج نهائي
وأنا  أنا أراقب المناورة الأولية
[موسيقى] ،
لقد سمعت للتو الترجمة
تؤكد أن الطيران قد
بدأ وأن معدل الإغلاق هو متر واحد
أنا في الصفحة 63.
انسخ وسنحصل للأسف على
بعض
مقاطع الفيديو المتقطعة ، وسيكون لدينا بعض
الانقطاعات في الإشارة خلال
الدقائق القليلة القادمة أو نحو ذلك ، لكن كل شيء
يستمر في المضي قدمًا بسلاسة
مع النهج الذي نحن فيه الآن في وضع الطيران هذا ،
لذا يرجى تقديم تعليق مفصل
للغاية وأكدت أن الطيران حول
النطاق الحالي هو
سعر إغلاق 330 هو
الحصول على 0.9 نسخة مؤكدة من الدورة الأولى
إحضارها لنسخ
[موسيقى]
300 متر هذا هو معدل إغلاق النطاق الحالي
هو 0.7
نسخة
[موسيقى]
حتى تحصل على كل شيء يسير مع
إرساء اليوم مباشرة على الجدول الزمني حتى الآن
مما
يعني أننا  قد ترسو حول
الوقت المستهدف وهو 2 45
مساءً في الوسط ، فنحن ننظر إلى غرفة التحكم
الآن حيث ننتظر الحصول على
ku أو
إشارة النطاق الترددي العالي للبيانات الخاصة بنا مرة أخرى
مع المحطة ، سنحصل على هذا الفيديو
قريبًا  الدخول والخروج خلال
الدقائق القليلة القادمة ،
لكننا مستمرون في الحصول على
تحديثات صوتية من alex للحصول على نهج على
متن الطائرة حيث ينتقل
إلى الفرق التي يعملون فيها حاليًا والتي
تطير حولها قريبًا وستدخل
ما يُعرف باسم المحطة  مع
الاحتفاظ ببعض
الضبط الدقيق الأخير لزاوية الاقتراب الخاصة بهم
لمنفذ الإرساء الفعلي وبعد ذلك
سيحين الوقت لنهج
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] [موسيقى]
النطاق الحالي هو 240 معدل الإغلاق هو 0.4
طيران في  التقدم المشترك
يتمتع جدار py بإطلالة رائعة على soyuz حيث
يستمر في الإغلاق في
مكان قريب ، يمكنك رؤية
تقدم راسي ومركبة soyuz الفضائية في
مقدمة رؤيتنا ،
فإن soyuz التي تصل اليوم ستكون
ثالث مركبة من هذا القبيل ترسو في
محطة الفضاء الدولية
وبذلك يصل إجمالي عدد السكان على
متن المركب إلى
تسعة أكبر عدد كان عليه منذ سبتمبر
2015.
30. معدل الإغلاق هو 0.20
تطير حول الموجز ،
نسخة مستمرة
[موسيقى]
هذه مركبة تقدم روسية في
المقدمة
تشبه إلى حد كبير  soyuz ولكنها تُستخدم
لنقل
البضائع وكذلك وقود المياه والإمدادات الأخرى
من وإلى محطة الفضاء الدولية أو إلى
محطة الفضاء الدولية
[موسيقى] ،
لذا استخدم ms-15 وسوف تستمر في التحليق وستذهب
طوال الطريق إلى
خدمة zvezda  وحدات إرساء المنفذ لذا
في الطرف الخلفي جدًا
من المحطة
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] النطاق 200 متر و 0.13 متر
في الثانية
هو معدل استمرار الطيران حوله
نحن نتجول بطريقة أو بأخرى ، نسختك
يا
[موسيقى]
تطير حولنا مستمر ، نحن
نتحرك حول sml
ونبدأ في الاقتراب من
نسخة عقدة الإرساء يمكننا رؤية عقدة الإرساء ،
هل يمكنك مشاهدة الفيديو
في الوقت الحالي نعم
[موسيقى]
الخشخاش
[  موسيقى]
نرى أيضًا مؤشر النهج النهائي
الذي ترى فيه إطلاقًا صاخبًا على
soyuz حيث
تنتهي وتطير حول المناورة في النهاية
محاذاة بشكل
صحيح مع الطرف الخلفي للمحطة ،
فنحن تقريبًا على طول محور
وفي الوقت المناسب نحن  لقد فقدنا إشارة الفيديو الخاصة بنا
، ونأمل أن نستعيدها في
غضون الدقائق القليلة القادمة ، واستمر في الحصول على
إشارة اقتراب المكالمات الصوتية من نسخة لعنة ،
كل شيء لا يزال مضاءً ، وما
زالت مناورة الدور مستمرة في
النسخ ،
لذا إذا كان لديك القدرة ، فيرجى الانتقال
إلى النهائي  اقترب على الفور من نسخ كل
ما نقف على أهبة الاستعداد لمزيد من المعلمات
[موسيقى]
نعم بالطبع محطة الاحتفاظ
بالممر المحرر مؤكدًا ،
يتم إضاءة النهج النهائي الخاص بك لبدء الموافقة
النهائية  أوه الآن
هذا هو فلاديمير بوتين
22 32 20 هو
مؤشر النهج النهائي للنسخة
لم نعد نتلقى الفيديو
بعد الآن أليكس لذا فإن
تعليقك اللفظي هو نسخة محل تقدير كبير ،
تم تأكيد إطلاق النار بالأمس النطاق هو 170.
آه المعدل يستمر في
الزيادة واه  تلقينا إشارة ما قبل الطفل
من لعنة
[موسيقى]
نسخة
[موسيقى
] المكالمة من النهج النهائي لدينا
لقد بدأ النهج النهائي للتأكيد ،
لذا فهم متقدمون بثلاث دقائق تقريبًا
على الجدول الزمني في الوقت الحالي
حتى تنتهي هذه الرحلة وتحتفظ بالمحطة
مناورة
ملحوظة واحدة مثيرة للاهتمام حول
الالتحام اليوم قاموا بالفعل بتدوير المحطة الفضائية
حوالي 180 درجة
التي تحدث أثناء المدار
وردية واحدة الليلة الماضية فقط ، وهذا
فقط للتأكد من أن النهاية الخلفية
للمحطة هي عادةً
النهاية الخلفية حيث تطير المحطة
فوق الأرض.  السطح في الواقع في
المقدمة الآن فقط لإعطاء ظروف إضاءة
جيدة لهذا النهج النهائي ورسو السفن
وبعد عملية إرساء ناجحة اليوم
بعد التحول في المدار الثالث ،
ستدور المحطة في نهاية المطاف
إلى اتجاهها المعتاد في الوقت الحالي على الرغم من أن
النهج النهائي قد بدأ
كل نهج إضافي جيد ، فقط
خمير وحوزة علي المنصوري يقتربان
من ميناء الإرساء الأخير إلى
المحطة الفضائية الدولية.
جاري النطاق
حوالي
100 متر 56 هو معدل
[موسيقى]
ما زلنا لا نرى
الفيديو النطاق حوالي 100 متر
نحن أه على طول محور
عقدة الإرساء ويمكنني رؤية
الشعيرات المتصالبة في
نسخة أوسكار باسكوب
النطاق هو 80 مترًا ،
ينظر يمينًا إلى مخروط الالتحام الموجود
على مركبة الفضاء سويوز نفسها ، لذا
تستمر في الإغلاق على
بعد 20 مترًا فقط على بعد حوالي 20 مترًا ،
إشارة على نسخة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
11 هو معدل النطاق 17
نسخة يمكننا أن نرى نفس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مرة أخرى أبطأ وثابت soyuz
يقترب من
حوالي عُشر متر في الثانية
USB الخشخاش يمكنني أن أرى زاوية لفة
هنا ليست  عند 2.13 كبير هو معدل الإغلاق
الذي يمكننا أن نرى أنه في هدف الفيديو
يكون أقل قليلاً من المركز ،
يتم محاذاة الشعيرات المتصالبة ، والقائمة
قريبة من الصفر
نقطة الخشخاش 11 هو معدل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يظهر على بعد 10 أمتار.  بعض
زاوية التدحرج هنا لا تزال الشعيرات المتصالبة
محاذية ،
فنحن في أوسكار
[موسيقى
] المعدل هو 0.1 ، لذا
يمكننا أن نرى أنه أيضًا نطاق
[الموسيقى]
هنا حوالي ثلاثة أمتار ونحن
نقف
بجانب نقطة الاتصال الأولى أه
عظيم  نسخة كنت على أهبة الاستعداد
لجهة الاتصال
التي تقف على أهبة الاستعداد للاتصال ورسو السفن ،
يبلغ نطاق [الموسيقى] حوالي 1 متر ، 0.1
هو معدل
نسخ [الموسيقى] ولذا أكدت أنك
ستأتي في الساعة 2
42 مساءً بالتوقيت المركزي 3 42 مساءً
بالتوقيت الشرقي بينما  كانت المحطة
وسويوز تحلقان 264 ميلًا قانونيًا فوق المحيط
الهادئ الجنوبي
قبالة الساحل الغربي لتشيلي ،
لذا تم تأكيد الالتحام مرة أخرى في الساعة 2 42 مساءً
بالتوقيت المركزي 3 42 مساءً
شرقًا ، رست ثلاثة أفراد جدد من الطاقم الآن
في محطة الفضاء الدولية ،
حسنًا ، دعنا ننتقل إلى الصفحة 66  لقد
تمكنوا الآن من الوصول إلى هناك
قبل الموعد المحدد بثلاث دقائق تقريبًا على
الرغم من أنهم سينتظرون
الحركة النسبية بين soyuz
والمحطة لتثبيط في
النهاية سلسلة من الخطافات ستشتغل
خلال الـ 15 دقيقة القادمة أو نحو ذلك  لتأمين
مركبة الفضاء soyuz في مكانها
التالي ، سيؤدي ذلك إلى بدء سلسلة من
عمليات التحقق من التسرب وكل ذلك يقودنا
إلى الطريق إلى فتح
هذه الفتحات في النهاية
مرة أخرى ، تم تأكيد 2 42 مساءً
بالتوقيت المركزي 3 42 مساءً شرق
[موسيقى]
انسخ ثم اذهب  إلى الصفحة التالية ، من فضلك
أضع جميع الخطوات وأعمل ،
سأرسل نسخة الأمر r7 ،
نقوم بإلغاء تنشيط نسخة الضوء الكاشف ،
نعم أغلقنا غير متاح
، وأولًا سيتراجع مسبار الإرساء
على soyuz وهذا
يسحب soyuz إلى أقرب حتى من منفذ الإرساء هذا
ثم يمهد الطريق لسلسلة
من الخطافات في كل من soyuz
ووحدة الخدمة في منفذ الإرساء
للتحرك والانخراط لماذا لا تقوم بعمل
رفيق صعب و  تثبيت soyuz بشكل آمن
في مكانه حيث سيبقى
لمدة ستة أشهر تقريبًا
تشغيل نظام غير مفهوم للصفحة 67.
[موسيقى]
في 15 دقيقة
ما زلنا في الصفحة 67 وإذا كنت
تنضم إلينا الآن فقد فاتتك أخطاء لا تشوبها شائبة
ورسو السفن الناجح
في الساعة 2 42 مساءً بالتوقيت المركزي
3 42 مساءً
شرقًا و 42 و 41 ثانية على وجه الدقة
أثناء تحليق المحطة لمسافة 262
ميلًا قانونيًا فوق المحيط الهادئ الجنوبي
في الوقت الحالي على الرغم
من انتقال السويوز إلى رفيقة صلبة
بحيث  يستغرق الأمر حوالي 14 إلى 15 دقيقة لرسو السفن المحترف الذي تم تعليقه في
النهاية على soyuz
ووحدة الخدمة نفسها ،
لذلك
نحن
سارة مارتي بواسطة زورق
سارماتي بايكونور
وتم سحب الحواف
نسخًا وزرًا أو المضي قدمًا
مساء الخير
كيف  هل تشعر أنك في
مزاج جيد هناك
نحن نشعر بتحسن وكل شيء
رمزي على متن الطائرة ، نحن بصدد الانتهاء من
اتفاقنا جيدًا ، لقد سمعنا للتو بعض المكالمات
من الفرق بالأسفل  الأرض لا تزال
تضم أه رئيس روز كوزموس
ديميتري فيرجوس وإعطاء الطاقم مكالمة
من بايكونور حيث كانوا
يشاهدون جميع الأحداث اليوم تتكشف
مرة أخرى أعضاء الطاقم الآن أليكس
لاقترابهم جيس كامير
رائد فضاء ناسا
وهزة علي  منصور ، رائد الفضاء
من الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
رست الآن في محطة الفضاء الدولية
عند الالتحام
قادمة في الساعة 2 42 مساءً بالتوقيت المركزي 3 42
مساءً شرقًا في الوقت الحالي ، سيحصلون على
بعض الوقت للخروج من
بدلات الإطلاق الجماعية والدخول التي قاموا بها.  كنا
نرتدي الملابس خلال الساعات القليلة الماضية
، ثم نجري سلسلة من فحوصات التسرب
أثناء الضغط على ما يعرف باسم
الدهليز ،
وهو المسافة بين فتحة soyuz
وفتحة المحطة الفضائية الدولية ،
سنقوم بهذه السلسلة من عمليات فحص التسرب.
تتوج
في النهاية بفتح الفتحة الفعلية لذلك
سيكون هناك فتحة على جانب المحطة
وفتحة في جانب soyuz
التي سيتم فتحها وبعد ذلك
سيبدأ أفراد الطاقم الثلاثة هؤلاء  N الستة
الموجودين حاليًا على متن الطائرة وسنكون عند تسعة
أشخاص على متن محطة الفضاء الدولية ،
لذا
سنستريح قليلاً وسنعود بهذه التغطية ،
لذا تأكد من العودة في الساعة 4 مساءً
بالتوقيت المركزي
في الخامسة مساءً شرقًا ، نتعقب فتحة
تفتح في
حوالي الساعة 4 45 مساءً بتوقيت وسط 5 45 مساءً شرقًا
ولكن من المعروف أن ذلك
قد مضى قليلاً أو متأخرًا قليلاً اعتمادًا
على مدى سرعة اجتيازهم عمليات فحص التسرب ،
لذا تأكد فقط من ضبطها
وسنتابع معًا وسرعان
ما سنرى عددًا أكبر من الأشخاص
على متن المحطة أكثر مما رأيناه في
حوالي أربع سنوات وقتًا مثيرًا للغاية ، ومن
بينهم
جيسيكا مير ، رائدة فضاء ناسا وهي تلقي
أول نظرة لها على متن المحطة
في  بعد بضع ساعات ، على الرغم من
أننا سنمضي قدمًا وتسجيل
الخروج الآن ، تأكد من الانضمام إلينا في
غضون
ساعتين تقريبًا سنعود بمزيد من
الإجراءات على متن محطة الفضاء الدولية
الآن على الرغم من أن هذه
هي مهمة التحكم في هيوستن
[موسيقى]
أنت